all right so this is Samsung's newest  addition in the Roman airport so you see  how the screens are all on these mounts  on that Center cylinder and then the  mounts look like they have a sort of  like pneumatic press or something see  look at this  yeah that's quite interesting look how  far out they extended everything  and now they're only rotating one level  it's interesting because I was thinking  about something like this for inside of  a home as a design challenge about two  three years ago or so  and you see this screen has no border  around outsides  yes there's what then - inside really  looks like  very very interesting  [Applause]  it's quite well done  and here's the roman airport what as far  as school